good evening everyone I am from Japan so
I'd like to start with a story about
Japanese fishing villages in the past
every fisherman was tempted to catch as
many fish as possible but if everybody
did that the fish commercial resourcing
the community would disappear the result
would be hardship and poverty for
everyone
this happened in some cases but it did
not happen in other cases in these
communities the fishermen developed a
kind of social contract that told each
one of them to hold back a bit to
prevent overfishing the fishermen would
keep an eye on each other they are to be
penalty if you were caught cheating but
once the benefit of social contract
became clear to everyone the incentive
to cheat dramatically dropped we find
the same story around the world this is
how villages in medieval Europe managed
pasture and forests this is how
communities in Asia managed water and
this is how indigenous peoples in the
Amazon managed wildlife these
communities did realize they did ID on a
finite shared resource they developed
rules and practice on how to manage
those resources and they changed their
behavior so that they could continue to
rely on those shared resources tomorrow
by not overfishing not by
bug racing not by polluting or depleting
water streams today this is a story of
the Commons and also how to avoid the so
called tricia.datene trade tragedy of
the Commons but this is also a story of
an economy that was mainly local where
everybody had a very strong sense of
belonging our economies are no longer
local when we moved away from being
local we started to lose our connection
to the Commons we carried economic
objective scores and systems beyond the
local but we did not carry the notion of
taking terrible Commons
so our oceans forests runs very close to
us as our local Commons moved very far
away from us so today we pumped millions
of tons of greenhouse gases into the air
we read um plastics fertilizers and
industrial waste into the rivers and
oceans and we cut down forests that
observe sea otters we make the world
biodiversity much fragile we seem to
have totally forgotten that there is
such a thing like global Commons air
water forests and biodiversity now it is
the modern science that reminds us how
vigo the global Commons are in 2009 a
group of scientists proposed how to
assess the health of the global Commons
they defined nine planetary boundaries
vital to our survival then they measured
how far we could go
we closed over the tipping points was
restful that of the leaders to the
irreversible or even catastrophic change
this is where we were in 1950s we
broadly remain within safe operating
space marked by the clean line but look
at where we are now we have a closed
four of those boundaries and we
recrossing
others in the future how did we end up
in this situation well my personal story
material something five years ago I was
appointed as CEO of the GEF global
environment facility but I am NOT an a
conservationist or non an environmental
activist I am an economist and for the
last thirty years I had worked for
public finance in my home country and
around the world I can tell you one
thing for sure during these 30 years the
notion of the global Commons never
crossed my mind I didn't have a single
conversation about the global Commons
with my colleague this tells me that the
nose of the global Commons must not
really entering into the big money
decisions like state budget or
investment plans and I'm wondering why
we have this sheer ignorance about the
global Commons including me myself one
possible explanation might be that until
recently it didn't really matter too
much even if we mess up some part of the
environment we were not fundamentally
changing the functions of the earth
system
the global Commons had still enough
capacity to take the punches we gave
them in fact the fish was still
plentiful that fields for grazing was
still vast our mistake was to assume the
capacity of the US for self repair had
no limits
it does have limits the message from the
science is very clear we human become an
overwhelming force to determine the
future living condition on us and what's
more we are running out of time if we
don't act on them we will be losing the
global Commons it's only about a nation
who are able to preserve it preserve the
Commons as we know them now it's a time
we started managing the global Commons
as our parents our grandparents managed
their local Commons the first thing we
need to do is to simply recognize that
we do have the global Commons and they
are very very important then we need to
build the stewardship of the global
Commons into all our thinking our
business our economy our participating
in all of our actions we need to
recreate the social contract of the
fishing villages on that global scale
but what does it mean practice where to
start with I see there are four key
economic system that fundamentally need
to change first we need to change our
cities by 2050 2000 we live in cities we
need clean cities second
need to change our energy system that
world economy must be sharply
decarbonize essentially in one
generation but we need to change our
production conception system we need to
break away from current take make waste
consumption pattern and finally we need
to change our food system what to eat
and how to produce it and all of those
four systems are putting enormous
pressure on the global Commons and it's
also very difficult to flip them they
are extremely complex with many distant
makers actors involved let's take an
example of the food system food
production is currently responsible for
one quarter of greenhouse gas emissions
it is also a main user of the world
water resources in fact 70% of the
today's water was used to grow crops
vast areas of coastal forests are used
for agriculture this deforestation
drives extinction in fact we are losing
species 1,000 times faster than natural
rate and on top of all those bad news
1/3 of food produced today globally is
not eaten it's it's wasted but there is
the good news good sign
coalition's of stakeholders are now
coming together to try to transform the
food system with one shared goal how to
produce in a healthy food for everyone
at the same time to try to come to
suddenly reduce the footprint from a
food system on the global Commons
I had an opportunity to fly over the
Indonesian island of Sumatra and I saw
with my own eyes
the master beautiful station for to make
the loom for palm oil plantation by the
way palm oil is included in thousands of
food product we eat every day the global
demand for palm oil is just increasing
in Samarra
I met small holder farmers who need to
make day-to-day living from growing oil
pan I met global food companies
financial institutions and local
government officers all of them told me
that they can't make that change by
themselves and only by working together
under a kind of new contract when new
practice do they have a chance to
protect tropical forests so it's so
encouraging to see at least for the last
few years this new coalition among these
committed actors along the supply chain
come together to try to transform the
food system in fact what they are trying
to do is to create a new kind of social
contract to manage the global Commons
all changes start at home at your place
and at my place at gef global
environment facility we have now a new
strategy and we put the global Commons
at its center I hope we won't be the
only ones if everybody stays the
sidelines and waiting for others to step
in that global Commons will continue to
deteriorate and everyone everybody will
be much worse off we need to save
ourselves from that tragedy of the
Commons
so I invite all of you to embrace that
global Commons please do remember the
global Commons to exist and are waiting
for your stewardship we all share one
planet in common we believe the same air
we drink the same water we depend on the
same ocean forests and biodiversity
there is no space left on earth for
egoism the global Commons must be kept
within a safe operating space and we can
only do it together thank you so much
[Applause]